So I have, like,
not been feeling well the last two days.
I have a syndrome called POTS.
Stands for postoral or stophatic tachycardia syndrome.
I probably just slaughtered that.
Here's the thing about syndromes.
They're all BS.
Like polycysco ovarian syndrome
and POT syndrome.
It basically just describes or explains
what symptoms you have.
It is not natural diagnosis.
Just like sudden infant death syndrome.
It basically means that my heart rate is
exceedingly fast
and that my blood pressure is very,
very low. And it gives me horrific side effects.
Sometimes I feel like I'm having a heart attack.
I can't breathe.
I'm having anxiety or a panic attack.
My legs will go numb.
And if your blood pressure drops too low
or you have seizures.
And because I'm carrying a baby
and my blood volume has tripled,
it has made my blood pressure drop even more
in my third trimester.
And I had this issue in my first trimester.
Are you telling us all this personal information, Holly?
Cause now they believe that one in four women
of childbearing years suffers from POTS.
And their significant studies
showing that it's all environmental.
Because it's America.
Land of the free and land of the sick.
Almost every woman I know of childbearing years
has some sort of autoimmune or chronic illness.
I went my whole 20s knowing
either have to get married
and let's look at our culture for that,
or be self sufficient at home,
where I Can make money
and not be forced to work outside
when I'm feeling deathly ill.
That is why I do digital marketing.
And so I can watch my baby.